the sound of the periodical cicadas
emerging in the east coast and midwest
is unmistakable
it's a symphony
hi my name is samuel ramsey i'm an
entomologist with the united states
department of agriculture i study
insects
last night i spent a good portion of my
night watching these cicadas beginning
to emerge watching them as they climbed
up fence posts and trees it was a
magical experience which i couldn't stop
myself from grabbing a few
cicadas are the loudest insects on the
planet and according to some estimates
this summer's brood 10 which has lived
in the soil for 17 long years could
number in the trillions oh yeah like the
national debt kind of trillion that
means that in some places there are as
many as one and a half million of them
per acre
crawling out of the dirt and up into the
trees where they shed their exoskeleton
and begin to emit a piercing sound that
seems to undulate
so we are listening to a chorus of male
cicadas so in order to actually amplify
the sound that they're producing cicadas
will chorus together they will gather
together and create a very loud song
that they're presenting to the female
cicadas of the world they are not just
producing one sort of noise it's an
intricate sound so this is the sound of
one cicada
[Applause]
they can be pretty loud they're ranging
in some ways from traffic noise
to pretty
loud garbage disposal
it is not a quiet insect so how does
such a big sound come out of something
so small
the answer lies in the cicada's unique
anatomy this guy right here if you see
that white patch
right there
that is the cicadas temple organ it is
what's capable of making that really
loud noise and there's one on each side
of the cicada's body they're generating
this sound unlike the ways that most
insects generate noise we think of noisy
insects and we think of
crickets
we think of katydids
but when we hear the sound generated by
a cicada it's not generated by rubbing
two parts of its body together they're
pulling on a section of their body that
is arranged like a musical instrument
and as they pull in the temple it
buckles these ribs on the sides of their
body that makes this very resonant loud
sound in addition to that the back end
of their body
like a lot of musical instruments is
hollow such that it can amplify this
noise and then their wings allows them
to direct it in different directions so
they are pretty much a musical
instrument all their own something that
immediately strikes me as really unique
about it is that it has a sound
in a lot of ways similar to something
called tuvan throat singing and it's a
type of singing uh that that has some
religious significance if i were to give
you a very amateurish example sounds
something like
[Music]
[Laughter]
and it's a type of singing uh that has
some religious significance a person is
able to uh through humming and
vocalizing create
sort of two
sets of notes playing at the same time
other insects like
bees don't typically use their sounds to
communicate over large distances bees
will create these vibrating noises that
they can use to communicate with other
bees to communicate with organisms that
they are attempting to ward off but
those are creatures that are pretty
close to their colonies so there's no
need for those sounds to be very loud
their blood red eyes and piercing shriek
might inspire fear in some
but not dr sammy ramsey who knows that
the song of the sikita is a key
component to their survival
this cicada
is not capable of harming me in any way
the only defense that they have is that
their numbers are so large that nothing
could possibly eat all of them and so
when they get into those trees it is
evolutionarily favored that they make as
much noise that they make the loudest
sound possible because if the loud
sounds are going to attract the females
well they want to make sure that they
can attract a female as quickly as
possible before something comes along
and attempts to eat them
they have the hugest biological
imperative to mate to find someone who's
going to be interested in this sound and
so in order to do that they may have to
really create a rather vibrant very loud
noise that can attract females from
quite a distance to ensure that they
haven't spent 17 years below ground for
nothing the cicadas have two typical
songs
one of the songs of course is the one
that that we've been discussing as this
reproductive imperative for them to
attract the attention of females so with
the cicadas it's all about this song
that they're able to produce and the
males that are able to produce a louder
song likely have larger muscles are
potentially bigger males and that may
mean that they're better at acquiring
nutrition and thus have genes that would
make them a better father of the
offspring of that female the males are
doing this all together and then they're
listening at the same time to see if
they can potentially hear the responsive
clicks that the female will make if she
is interested in it
now the female makes a sound like this
it's not unless you get a female cicada
very close to you that you'll be able to
hear somewhat subtle clicking noise that
they make that noise is not supposed to
be incredibly resonant it's more of a
directed noise to get the attention of a
male that's close by and they get so
excited about this because of all the
time that they have been waiting for
this that they will go after
anything and i mean anything that makes
a rhythmic clicking noise and so that's
power tools that people are using
outside that's lawn mowers even just
snapping
can be something that can attract male
cicadas to you
but the other song is a warning call
this is the distress sound
it seems to be a call to actually make
sure that the rest of the population of
cicadas can get away and not be killed
and so
it's remarkable but cicadas continue to
show that they have an all for one one
for all kind of dynamic going where they
are intently trying to make sure that
they can pass on their genes and that
those around them can as well once
they've made it the females lay their
eggs in the trees and die within a few
weeks 10 weeks later their eggs hatch
the larva fall and burrow into the
ground and the 17-year cycle begins
again just beautiful i know that it's
fairly easy for people to hear this and
think of it as just a bunch of loud
random purposeless noise but these
creatures
the sound that they're producing here
it can even create an emotional response
for you to consider what they have been
through and what they are looking
forward to i can't stop drawing
parallels between us and the pandemic
and all over the world as people have
had the opportunity to reach a sense of
normalcy after being in these these
situations where they're isolated from
other people and it seems
like we aren't that different from these
creatures after all they look so
different but they're after so many of
the same things they're after
camaraderie they're after the
opportunity to be with other individuals
and they love music the cicadas are
about to make some things happen and it
is truly a bop this is certified by and
i hope that you are willing to really
listen to it for what it is
girl i'm telling you
you
are the only one i've got these big red
eyes for